[Music]
hydrogen has a very special place in the
universe
it's the first element on the periodic
table
it is the most abundant element in the
universe
and when clean energy advocates think
about what can we find which would be as
easy to use as fossil fuels they think
about hydrogen
the fuel that will when burned only
produce water
[Music]
we like to imagine that if we just built
enough of these and these we could ditch
fossil fuels and save the planet
unfortunately it's not that simple there
are some things where you just need good
old-fashioned combustible fuel
now startups around the world are
betting that hydrogen can become the
fuel of the 21st century
just like today we use fossil fuels for
different applications like power plants
cars and trucks and trains hydrogen will
be used for all this variety of
different applications
eventually the world's going to have to
care about co2 as soon as you start to
care about co2 hydrogen becomes pretty
interesting
but turning the most common element in
the universe into the new fuel of choice
is harder than it might seem
[Music]
the first thing you need to know about
hydrogen is that not all hydrogen is
created equal
allow us to introduce the hydrogen
rainbow
hydrogen is unique because you can
generate it in many different ways and
the different ways in which it is
created actually are defined by colors
the rainbow scales from the most
environmentally friendly to the least
grey hydrogen means taking natural gas
and converting that into hydrogen while
creating co2 emissions in the process
blue hydrogen is gray hydrogen but with
carbon capture instead so there are no
co2 emissions that are put into the
atmosphere instead they are captured and
buried deep underground
there's also pink hydrogen where you use
nuclear power to create hydrogen
one color is prized above them all
green
green hydrogen is the hydrogen that
everybody wants because it's the
hydrogen that uses renewable electricity
to split water into hydrogen and oxygen
if we could make enough green hydrogen
we'd have a clean fuel source with
incredible versatility making
electricity whenever we need it powering
heavy industry and theoretically even
replacing fossil fuels in some of the
most polluting forms of transportation
today though most hydrogen is produced
on the polluting end of the spectrum
so engineers are working on getting
green hydrogen up to speed
at h2 pro we're developing a new
technology that splits water into
hydrogen and oxygen
the environment was always uh
dear to me i remember as the kid
uh having this poster in my room the
earth and was written on it
fragile handled with care
and being here is a tremendous
opportunity to actually do something
about it
talmud marco founded and sold two app
companies for more than a billion
dollars before following his green
dreams and starting h2 pro in 2019.
the process of splitting water has been
known for over 200 years you put two
electrodes in a glass of water
with some salt turn on the flour and you
get hydrogen and oxygen bubbles
today i was in the my sun classroom and
i showed them an experiment of how we
can split water
very easily i just took a 9 volt battery
place it in the water with some salt
and voila you have hydrogen and oxygen
coming out
that's nice but
it's very very inefficient
and therefore very very costly
the hard thing is how to make hydrogen
efficiently
and with low cost
our technology is different in the fact
that it's more efficient and it's
cheaper to manufacture resulting in
cheaper hydrogen for customers
that's made possible by a fancy
engineering trick
conventional electrolyzers use
electricity not just to create hydrogen
molecules but also to separate out
unwanted oxygen molecules
h2 pro found a way to separate the
oxygen using heat instead
we have the oxygen being released just
by raising the temperature
so we are releasing the oxygen without
applying any power
this is the reason why we can be
so much more efficient
this is the unique technology of
age to pro these specific electrodes
themselves they release the oxygen the
next level when we're going to make our
factory it's going to work in a very
similar approach like here
h2 pro is fighting an uphill battle just
by virtue of being green
electrolysis makes up just two percent
of hydrogen production today and many
investors didn't see the potential for
growth
initially it was very
very difficult to raise money for h2 pro
in fact we had to reach to over 100
funds until we managed to get the
company funded
scaling is never easy our system
produces 500 000 times more hydrogen
than where we were three years ago but
we still have a ways to go
the ultimate test will be where the h2
pro can make its product cheaply enough
to race ahead of its more established
competition
the long-term goal for hydrogen to
become a viable fuel is for it to cost
between a dollar or two dollars a
kilogram
we are nowhere close to that we are
probably in the three or four or five
dollars range for green hydrogen today
we anticipate that our customers will
have a cost of about one dollar per
kilogram of green hydrogen by the end of
this decade
companies like h2 pro still have a long
way to go before they're producing green
hydrogen at scale
but being green isn't the only way to be
green
that'll make sense in a minute
we describe what we're doing at c0 as
turquoise hydrogen because it's kind of
a combination of both blue and green in
that it's low cost
and low emission
czero has developed a technology for
removing the carbon in natural gas
natural gas is a hydrocarbon it's made
out of hydrogen and carbon and what we
do is
remove the carbon
and so we pull out the solid carbon out
of the hydrogen that we produce and
there are no direct co2 emissions
because anything that would have been
co2 is instead solid carbon
if you want to get hydrogen from water
it takes seven and a half times as much
energy to go pull hydrogen off of oxygen
by splitting water as it does to pull
hydrogen off of carbon through our
process
the way c0 achieves it is using molten
salts
it has a big chamber full of salt that
is heated to a very high temperature
so this is an example of one of our
laboratory scale reactors so right here
we have a very high temperature around a
thousand degrees and slightly above
molten media column
and it bubbles natural gas through that
chamber leaving behind carbon in its
elemental form and hydrogen is a gas
that can be trapped and sold
if we're successful we're producing
piles of black carbon that ultimately
gets sequestered back into the ground
you can think of it almost as
pre-combustion carbon capture rather
than ending up with co2 that you have to
concentrate compress put into a pipeline
and inject it underground we pull out
ahead of times a solid that's much
denser
and you can move around with
conventional solids handling equipment
and dispose of
just like green hydrogen the success of
turquoise hydrogen will ultimately come
down to cost
a dollar fifty per kilogram of hydrogen
is our target for doing this at very
large scale
if you can be two dollars a kilogram or
less with you know very low to zero co2
emissions that's kind of a game changer
the tough economics of hydrogen can make
it sound like we're a long way from
reaching the cleaner end of the rainbow
and it's true that companies like c0 and
h2 pro are going to have to make
hydrogen at vastly larger scales before
they can make a dent in fossil fuel
consumption
[Music]
but some industrial companies aren't
waiting for the economics to be perfect
before making the switch
even in one of the most polluting
industries in the world
ssab is a steel company having a
production capacity of approximately 9
million tons of steel products per year
we alone accounts for 10 percent of
sweden's total co2 emission
if we want to cut emission we can't
continue with the current platform based
technology we need to change technology
so that's exactly what ssab did
developing a way of replacing coal with
hydrogen in their steel making process
in the process of making steel a factory
has to convert iron ore into iron
iron ore is iron plus oxygen
the removal of oxygen requires typically
the use of coal which will combine with
oxygen to form co2 and warm the planet
you could also use green hydrogen to
take the oxygen away and that will only
produce water
our aim is to decarbonize the whole
value chain from mining to iron making
steel making but also deliver final
product to our customers without using
fossil fuel that's the egg
we believe this is going to contribute
not only cutting our own emissions but
this technology can also be used by
others when they are ready to take this
step
it's not going to be easy for industries
to take full advantage of hydrogen even
when production costs come
down storing and transporting the stuff
is something of a nightmare and since
hydrogen is extremely flammable safety
is always a concern
just look at the hydrogen zeppelins of
the early 20th century
but if we can overcome the economic and
engineering challenges the most abundant
element in the universe could provide
the abundant energy we need
i want to see a decarbonized future but
i'm also an engineer a practicalist and
a realist and that
transition to a low carbon future is not
going to happen overnight and we need
realistic
transition options and technologies that
allow us to decarbonize our existing
applications
i love this company
i love the people i work with
and we're all in this together
for this
almost sacred mission
this is our duty for our children and
for our grandchildren or for generations
to come
[Music]
you